[Music]
I now call upon Mr Rashmi B zavi to
present his response to Dr Zakir nyak
ladies and gentlemen Mr Rashmi Bay
[Applause]
zi first of all I really thank Dr Jakir
nyak for giving me the choice whether I
would like to still remain a vegetarian
or
nonvegetarian thank you very much I
would request uh Mr
coordinator that
uh would you like to have the rebuttal
or my comments now or shall we have
because after all you know this is now
it's better you know we'll let's have
some question answer if you think
question answer we have in the third
session we have three-part
session
yes Mr Z you can
continue now we are totally at the
command of the coordinator so I will as
decided you know the same format we I
will obey I will not allow Dr Zakir also
to change the format now I'll object
first thing that I will say it's not a
question
of whether one is logical or illogical
and it's not a question of the choice
that one makes as I said in my talk
earlier everything is relative and you
have to understand this topic from that
perspective
now one thing that I will very strongly
object with respect to Dr Jakir that not
a single religion prohibits non W I am
expert I can say because I am a student
I have done Ma in genology I can say
from my religion ious point of view that
Lord mahavir and our all 24 taras very
vly prohibited nonv food I have already
given you some quotations you see mainly
arguments of Dr Dean orish uh is based
on the fact that nonv food contains
excessive protein cholesterol and
saturated fat so that is why he said
that for healthy and peaceful Liv living
you must have non veg
diet
now he said that plant has also got life
no it is not only proved by Dr jish
Chandra BOS but even our Lord mahavir he
stated 2,500 years ago that not only
plant
air water fire minerals of the earth
they all have life he has not said that
you are allowed to kill this life and
maintain yourself but he was a
practical tankar so he said that those
who cannot renounce this world and
become Jane monei you know Jane
munis they don't even kill plant
vegetation or even other uh living
beings for their food they beg the food
which is cooked in our house will not go
into that controversy that even you kill
it and then give them that's a separate
story but the teachings of mahavir are
very clear that you shall not harm any
living being whether animate or
inanimate now because of certain
constraint for those people who cannot
renounce the world he has said that at
least you can avoid essential killing he
has said that even if you went you have
food made out of plant it is violence it
is hinsa but it is necessary so what I
prohibit is unnecessary friends this a
very sharp distinction but very
important distinction we should make
that if the alternative is available we
should not go for that alternative which
compels us to kill and eat our own
fellow creatures
another thing
so he said
plants in my talk I stated about plant
food and he said that even a lizard can
grow tail that's the only exception the
plants you pluck fruits they will give
you more fruits you cut their branches
more branches will grow see there is no
end to such argument so let us restrict
our argument to this about medical
science and he rightly stated that
medically also he has given certain
things I have also stated now it is for
the enlightened audience to decide
whether the scientific facts that I have
given are correct or he has given it
it's okay it's a question of argument
now he has conveniently forgotten please
excuse me I'm telling because I'm trying
to rebutt your things the psychological
aspect when we consume animal food we
also inherit certain animal instincts
what have you to say please in your
rebuttal you can say that now doctors
also most of the doctors prescribe raw
vegetable now coming to cooking most of
the doctors prescribe raw vegetables for
healthy diet only that food or cereals
which will not be proper for a human
being to consume roow that only can be
good but as far as possible and in our
Indian vegetarian Congress we always
whenever we have meeting we have most of
the food row uncooked and that is more
healthy according to us
about the books these books were not
given by me to Dr nyak and it was given
by my friend Mr Sala who approached me
that's okay there nothing very important
now I will tell you one thing that you
cannot alter the truth by just loud
Applause okay if you are impressed by my
argument you may Applause me or if you
are impressed by the other argument you
can Applause that but I firmly believe
that just because some arguments are
appealing to you and you Applause them
loudly will not alter the truth and
U I will I have referred to about one
book uh one doctor deak Chopra he has
also written many books he is also a
physician practicing physician like Dr
de ornish he has also conducted
researches and he has come out with a
theory that your food will have a
terrific effect effect on your impulses
and urges your physical development
psychological development and emotional
development you know most of the
psychological and emotional distortions
are because of the flesh food that one
eats and that is why it is
prohibited it is totally illogical to
say that by eating animals you are
helping vegetarians we should not worry
about the animal population because
nature is quite capable of taking care
why because
we are because we are raring more an
animals for killing that is why that if
we are not doing it look at the jungle
everywhere the natural cycle is there
balancing will take care of itself
nobody has to worry about
it now
asper the history that Mr tried also
referred and also Dr Jakir now I will
tell from J historical point of view
that in our Jane Scriptures it is
mentioned very clearly
that the PE those persons who were
living in prehistoric stage they lived
under a tree and they were sufficiently
provided by trees they did not have to
go for any killing friends I of course
given more time but I'm I really
personally feel that let's not have a
sort of dialogue or arguments between I
would like very much the audience to
participate and have more time for
question answer thank
you
thank you Mr zi we have uh five minutes
more it's taking five minutes
left now I call upon Dr Zakir n to
present his response to Mr Rashmi bavi
for 15 minutes
only
alhamdulillah
the respected people on the D and my
respected elders and my brothers and
sisters I welcome once again all of you
with Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana tal be on all of you I
have not conveniently forgotten anything
if you realize I spoke Maybe half minute
more than the time alloted so how can
you say I conveniently forgot if you
give me even 5 hours more if you're
willing to
stay because you are the person who kept
time restrictions you know less time 30
I had to bargain for 50 minutes I would
love to speak for two hours even full
day I can do it because I'm a marathon
speaker
alhamdulillah I'm a
non-vegetarian
Mr zavi
said that I said that no religion
prohibits non I never said no religion I
said no major religion it's being
recorded no major religion and jism is
not a major religion according to the
books you gave me you gave certain books
Jens are only 4% of India point4 less
than 1% can you call it a major religion
in India Li side world world out of the
question negligible I am very clear in
my statement regarding the argument on
jism I can reply but the coordinator
won't give me permission I'm restricted
to Islam you know I can reply even on
jism I'm a St of
comparative excuse me sir you can't
interfere when the speaker is speaking
brother is saying I did not say you can
very well see the video cassette there
is not a single major religion which
bans or prohibits all non-v food in
general you can see the video casset ask
your question in question time please
don't get rated the diet will help you
don't
get brother Rashmi said I did not answer
whether you get animal Instinct I said
in my lecture I think you didn't hear I
said we eat peaceful animals like go
sheep because we want to be peaceful and
therefore when I came starting I always
said Peace be on all of
you further he said I didn't State Dr de
Onish I yet challenge him if his book
is referred by any authentic Medical
College authentic book not just dietary
books that answer already gave by Dr
William T Jaris even scientists and
medical professionals are not immune to
the ideological thinking of the
vegetarians they aren't immune it's not
a medical book he might have a died book
I'm very clear in my words I don't mix
words and Dean Onish whatever his name
is may be very famous I don't know him
I'm hearing for the first time
I don't know I yet ask him to prove and
check whether that book is referred as a
text book not as a medical book a text
medical book in a college that shows
authenticity he said we should not worry
about the cattle nature will take care
it is you all are so much worrying we
aren't worrying Nature Made Them in such
a way that the moment you kill them they
will again come God is the creator Allah
made them if we kill lion tiger they
will become extinct therefore we cannot
have their food the cattle we can have
God has made them that way if we don't
follow the instruction of God there will
be overp
population and regarding cutting of
plants what he said you know people say
that if you have plants the mother is
yet alive so in that way The Offspring
of the cow of the goat the Cs that means
can we cut them yes the mother is yet
alive the cow is that alive and when The
Offspring becomes a mother you can also
kill the mother so even if I agree with
this Logic the plant survives in the
animals more lives are surviving than
the plants if I agree with this
logic furthermore I
said that best is prevention is better
than cure I agree with Dr Onish when he
says that you know vegetan di is
healthful for certain disease even I
advise that where I said no but the
topic is not which food is
healthier but making a statement it is
banned for human beings I challenge any
authentic medical book I'm a doctor not
books whether given by Russia Foundation
or Indian Congress whatever it is these
books are stating things which are
unfound ill tested
unproved there's the Islamic method of
prevention better than cure which will
answer most of your questions the
Islamic method is there of prevention
better than cure when we SED animal we
do the Zab we cut the throat and the
wind pipe and the vessel of of the neck
without damaging the spinal cord
otherwise the nerve going to the heart
may get severed there will be Cardiac
Arrest when the spinal cord is not
damaged and the vessels of the neck are
slit open along with the throat and the
wind pipe the heart is pumping most of
the blood flows out of the body blood is
a very good media of germ and bacteria
if you Slaughter the animal in this way
most of the disease transmits by Blood
many which you named can be
eliminated can be prevented
the meat remains fresh for a longer time
if it's slaughtered by the Islamic
method and people say oh it's a
merciless you know you are so
mercilessly killing it dies of
pain when we sorten the Islamic method
when we cut the blood vessels of the
neck the blood supply going to the nerve
which is responsible for pain is severed
so the animal does not feel pain the
animal kicks and R you know why due to
the gush of flow the animal doesn't feel
pain it is Contracting and relaxing
because there's lack of blood in that
part of the body the animal does not die
of pain it dies of painless death
painless
painless we eliminate most of the
disease transmitted by Blood secondly
there are many countries in the world
and many people who raise animals they
give them hormones and one was mentioned
by Mr Z he name it's called as
D diol it's a hormone injected to cattle
so that they become fat and you get more
money for flesh this is Haram in Islam
carcinogenic hormones if ingest an
animal even if you Slaughter by the
zabya method it is yet Haram it is zabya
but not Halal it is zabya and Haram if
the C are injected with hormones you are
not allowed to have those hormones
neither are you allowed to have cows
which are fed with non wge because the
prophet said any animal that is fed with
nonv it is prohibited for
you after that if you take care of
hygienic conditions and cook the meat
very
well most of the diseases which Mr zavi
spoke or not all most of them will be
eliminated and In the non-w Flesh food
the most dangerous which is commonly
eaten is
poke it has more than 70 different
diseases which you can get if you inest
pooke more than 70 different diseases
and one of them is isic heart disease
which he spoke about because poke has
more of fat Building Material than
muscle building material it gets
deposited on the walls of the vessels
causing arcis hypertension
Etc that's the reason in the Quran no is
in four different places in Surah Bak
chapter number 2 verse 173 in Sur ma
chapter number 5 verse number three in
chter number 6 verse number 145 and
chter number 16 verse number 115 it
says
for for you for food dead meat blood the
Flesh of swine and any food on which any
name besides God's name has been invoked
it's Haram so we abstain from it and we
prevent several diseases of nonwe Quran
says in Surah T chapter number 20 verse
number 81 eat of the food we have
provided for you in sustainance but
commit no excesses therein most of the
diseases what Mr Rashmi spoke about is
due to excessive eating even if you eat
excessive veg food you will have many
diseases I will not say don't have veg
food I'm a doctor I'm not an ideological
neither a fanatic
non-vegetarian so if you prevent eating
in excess most of the disease will
prevented if you follow the Islamic
guidelines Slaughter in the Islamic
method remove the blood don't give
hormones cook the food very well
hygienic conditions avoid poke don't eat
in excess most of the disease can be
prevented it answers most of his
arguments few are yet remaining if time
permits or in question answer time if
you ask I will
reply do you know they're talking about
healthy food healthy food talking about
all research and experiments I'll talk
something which is a
fact according to Dr
William again very famous person Dr
William he says that vegetarian food
extends the life of a human being for
more than 6 years
if you have veg food as compared to
non-v food you live 6 years longer again
hypothesis
hypothesis if you
analyze a data was collected about all
the people who lived above 100 years
from 1932 to
1952 and on this data a person by the
name of oares he wrote a book living to
be 100 1,200 people who did and why they
did it everything is mentioned in it
even diet is mentioned do you know out
of 1,200 people how many were vegetarian
how many
guess 1,000 four
four
four this survey wasn't done to prove
veg food or non-v food it was done for
other reasons but even the diet was
mentioned it's a fact it's not a
research it's a fact out of 1,200 people
who lived in the span of 20 years over
100 years only before
vegetarian you know alcohol alcohol
alone it is a veg diet or not alcohol is
veg or non-v V from juices of fruits and
the disease that are caused by alcohol
alone is more than all the non disease
put together one vegetable that so just
for alcohol I cannot say that all
vegetable food should be
banned today scientist and will agree
it's mentioned in these books also the
cause of Maximum death in the world
today is alcohol number one so I don't
ban all veeg food what do I say as Quran
says number 5 vers
number that oh you belief verily
intoxicants and gambling and idol
worship and edication of stones and
divination of arrows these are Satan's
handywork abstain from it that you may
Prosper alcohol is a Satan's handwork
abstain from it I only prate alcohol not
all W food
and smoking second greatest cause of
death in the world veg or non-v veg can
you prevent the alcoholic disease only
way you can prevent is Def fermented
it's easiest to be alcohol can you
prevent smoking disease don't have
tobacco only option is prohibition if
there is no prevention then comes the
question of prohibition so alcohol is
prohibited there are more than 400 by
Islamic scholars smoking is prohibited
because there no prevention you know k
k Indian government has banned it it
causes paraplegia staple food of
Northwest
Indians banned why it causes death also
paria alcohol many countries are
bland including Saudi Arabia including
states in India have banned it smoking
in Singapore is banned in public places
in government places in public
transport qu banned by India if there's
no prevention then you can ban it I do
not know of a single government that has
banned all non-w food in general not a
single yes few non-w food like poke
Saudi Arabia has BN there's no
prevention B it if there's no prevention
then you prohibit it and the debate was
not which is better which is healthier
veg or non-v the debate was is non- food
permitted or prohibited I gave a list of
more than 20 points so I can very well
say that Mr Rashmi conveniently stopped
his talk 5 minutes before not to answer
these things if you give me one hour
more I will continue
speaking wild berries they poisonous
stretchin vegetable food they're
poisonous data
poisonous what's the solution don't have
it
you know water water has so many
diseases transmitted chera paratyphoid
typhoid it causes amasis gasis round
worm pinworm V hepatitis I can go on
talking only by water what do you do do
you band
water you prevent it you purify the
water the disease will
prevented you know milk milk has so many
diseases Shiga Kera paratyphoid typhoid
t osis salonis brucelosis I can go on
listing what do you do do you ban milk
what do you do you pasteurize it you
don't band it you don't prohibit it it's
unmedicated
topic I won't argue on
that so if you cannot prevent the
disease then do you prohibit it I have
given various reasons which Mr hasn't
replied there's not a single government
who has banned non food in general
there's not a single major religion
which has banned non-v food in general
therefore I say that non-v food is
permitted not prohibited if I heard the
feelings of any vegetarians while giving
the replies to the speaker I sincerely
apologize from the bottom of my heart I
would like to end the talk by giving the
quotation of the Glorious Quran from is
chapter number 17 verse number 81 which
says when truth is H against falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to
[Applause]
perish now we begin the open question
and answer
session to extract maximum benefit in
the limited time that we have available
in the question and answer
session we expect the following rules to
be
observed your question should be on the
topic only that is is nonvegetarian food
permitted or prohibited for a human
being questions out of the topic will
not be
permitted kindly State your question
briefly and to the
point this is not a lecture time neither
a cross question time for the
questioners I repeat kindly State your
question briefly and to the point this
is not not a lecture time neither a
counter question time for the
questioners Mr zi and Dr Zakir should
answer
comprehensively and each answer should
not exceed five
minutes four mics have been provided in
the auditorium two next to the stage for
the gents and two in the rare Central a
for the
ladies if you wish to put a question to
Mr zaeri kindly queue up behind the mic
with the name clip question for Mr zi
similarly so in the ladies and if you
wish to put a question to Dr Zakir
kindly queue up behind the mic with the
name clip question for Dr
Zakir only one question at a time may be
asked for your second question you would
have to go right at the back of the
queue again and await your second
chance written questions on slip papers
which are available from The Volunteers
in the aisles would be given secondary
preference if time
permits on your
slip where you're putting a question
kindly tick or write to whom your
question is addressed Mr zi or Dr Zakir
or it might be put
aside kindly state your name and
profession before putting forward your
question so that the speakers would be
in a better position to answer
you we would allow one question on each
of the mics in a clockwise
rotation alternately addressed to each
speaker may we have the first
question from the mic on my left so we
have first gents ladies to then gents
again yes brother we can have the first
question from
you that's for Mr zi yeah yes respected
Chief guest and Mr
Jai my question is you have spoken
nonvegetarian is prohibited from various
angles and you have spoken about your
lord mahavir mahavir advised that
killing animals and living happy at the
expenses of other is prohibited now
please explain to
me did mahavir say that can you eat
vegetarian vegetarian in the sense I
mean mahavir never go and cut trees and
have vegetable Foods he was always
sitting under the tree and the food
which he has eaten is mostly fruits
which has fallen from the tree he was
not plugging up the fruits and ate so
please explain to me because you have
spoken on the subject of this vegetarian
non-vegetarians prohibited for the thing
and please explain to me what is the
Jane view because your idea your idea is
the what Mah said what M I understood
your question I will reply see what Lord
I was stated already that what Lord
mahavir stated that even plant has got
life and he says that even eating
vegetable food is as per the Jane
scriptures is prohibited for Jan monei
but because of constraint everybody
cannot become a Jane monei that is why
he said that at least the unnecessary
killing of animals should be avoided he
never said that eating of plant food is
allowed even for Jane
munis yes s question for Dr
Zakir asalam alikum brother Zakir I'm H
Maya I have a question there are various
pamphlet distributed by a vegetarian
Society quoting the Quran from Sur Hajj
that it is not the meat nor the blood
that reaches Allah but your p that
reaches him thus proving that Islam
prohibits killing of animals for foul
there are many quotations from Quran and
Hadith showing concern for
Animals I would like to thank the sister
she has asked a very fundamental
question that there are certain pamphlet
distributed by
organizations proving from the Quran and
Hadith that non-v food a Muslim should
not have it is prohibited and this was
the initiation of this debate I didn't
touch on it because you know they told
me to keep out of religion but since
it's a question I'm compelled to answer
this was a pamphlet
that the president of Kusha Foundation
Mr D salesa he gave and how this debate
was initiated he gave this pamphlet
quoting from the
Quran I'll just give also reference the
reference is a bit wrong out there but I
don't catch on the reference he's
quoting a verse from Surah Haj chter 22
verse number 37 which says that that it
is not their meat nor their blood which
reaches Allah which reaches God but it
is your P reaches him and I agree with
that totally it's indicating that Islam
is not like certain other religions
which believe that almighty God requires
blood and meat to survive it's saying
that when you sacrifice blood doesn't
reach God meat doesn't reach God it is
your intention it is the
righteousness it's the pety which you
sacrif
Allah considers that
pety that is the reason when we
sacrifice in minimum one3 portion of
that animal has to be given compulsory
to the poor people oneir can be given to
friends and relatives and maximum one
third you can keep for personal use
there is no part kept for almighty
God because Quran says in Surah Anam
chapter 6 verse 14 that he feeded
everyone but does not require to be fed
Allah almighty God feeds everyone he
doesn't require to be fed this verse is
clear that when you sacrifice Allah sees
your intention he doesn't require blood
and meat of the animal there's one more
quotation there are where is it will
take me one hour to reply to all I'll
just pick up the second quotation of
Quran the two quranic quotation it says
in Sur Bak CH 2 verse number 25 that
when they turn away they create Mischief
through the land by destroying crops and
cattle Allah loves not those who make
mischief after giving this quotation
below its
mention that therefore you should not
have non-w their
interpretation the Arabic word used is
nasal which some have translated as
cattle it actually means
progeny but irrespective whether nusle
you translate as CLE or progeny if you
read the context those people who create
Mischief throughout the world by
destroying crops and Catal of progyny
not slaughtering for food destroying for
creating Mischief Allah does not like
those who make Mischief so if you kill
any animal even the plant if you kill
for making
Mischief Allah doesn't like if you say
this words refers to not having for food
that means you should not even have the
crops if I agree with you this verse
refers not to have cattle even crops is
there it is a very wrong way of argument
they don't do self analysis crop is also
mentioned there if they say by this
words nonv is prohibited if even veg is
prohibited it is
not neither nonv is prohibited neither
veg is prohibited certain foods which
Allah has prohibited mentioned in the
Quran the others Allah says in Surah Bak
CH 2 vers 168 eat of the good food we
have provide for you regarding animal
concern yeah there are various
Hadith if you read s bukari volume
number three Hadith number 551 and S
bukari volume number8 had number 38 it
speaks about a man who gave water to a
Thirsty Dog and Prophet said he'll be
rewarded Reed so people asked do you
even have reward for giving water to a
Thirsty Dog the prophet said yes for
every kind act you do to the animal
you'll be rewarded imagine in the days
of
ignorance 14400 years ago where human
beings were treated like animals our
beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam spoke about animal
rights Prophet said don't overload the
animals you know today in India two
Bullocks are supposed to carry by law
not more than 500 kgs they carry more
than a ton Prophet said don't overload
them don't ill treat them don't tie them
and shoot them mentioned s Muslim volume
number
three Hadith number 4,812 it's also
mentioned s bukari don't tie the animal
and shoot
them it's mentioned in s Muslim volum
number three Hadith number
4,810 that when you Slaughter the animal
see to it that the knife is sharp so
that the animal doesn't feel pain
don't Slaughter one animal in front of
the other don't kill the animal
twice he said that you know adrenaline
is released it relas in the blood the
blood goes out of the body Prophet spoke
about animal concern we should protect
the rights but for food if it's lawful
animal you can have it hope to answer
the
[Applause]
question yes
sister it's mentioned the book 100 facts
about
egg on page number 8 and N fact number
13 ethopians are of the view if a
pregnant woman eats eggs her child would
be born baldheaded and would be
deficient in reproduction it's also
mentioned in uh fact number 18 some
African countries believe that if a
child is given to eat egg before feeding
he may become mentally are
these signs scientific facts or these
superstitions if you say these are
scientific facts then could you please
prove it authentically and if you say
it's
Superstition then why are you promoting
falsehood by such books that's 100 facts
about egg thank
you thank you sister one thing I have
not written that book second thing I
have not given that book to you and I am
not I not ref to anything from that book
so it is not necessary to answer for
particularly for that book but I can
definitely say which I have already
touched upon in my subject because egg
contains excessive protein and
cholesterol and saturated fed that is
why it is not healthy for any human
being and particularly for pregnant
woman and
children yes the next question from the
M on the on the
right I am Fel Sarang by profession I am
an architect my question is to Mr Dr
Zaki Nik is the non nonvegetarian food
is the only reason for the heart
disease the brother asked a very good
question that is nonv the only reason
for the heart disease and this was
spoken by Mr zi that flesh animal flesh
chicken mut beef causes heart disease it
can cause he's right and he further said
there is not a single vegetable source
which contains
cholesterol if you tell that to any
doctor not the ideological vegetarian
they'll
agree hard disease is caused when the
diet contains more fat and more
cholesterol irrespective whether it's
veg or non-v
irrespective nonv foods do contain high
cholesterol but even vegetable Foods
ground nut oil cashew nut
coconut ghee butter all this even a
common housewife knows you know why
there are ads in the media have Safa oil
will not cause heart
disease indicating the other oils cause
heart disease simple you don't have to
be a doctor it's a blatant 100%
falsehood I being a medical doctor I
challenge I challenge Mr Rashmi to
answer does butter contain fat or not
and the doctors do tell the people
suffing heart disease don't have fat
don't have butter don't have ground nut
oil don't have cashew nut oil so where
did you get this idea
from from these
books this book he gave to me correct
this book you gave to my brother who
gave Mr
salesa Mr salesa gave this book in this
book also it is mentioned the same thing
that there is no cholesterol in
vegetables I'm sorry if I thought
because the first time I'm meeting Mr
zavi here if you didn't give these books
I
apologize but but one thing that all
these books are published by J
organization and distributed mombay
cheap yes I'm I'm not blaming I don't
want to let us not have a dialogue
across the this thing I'm not going to
hurt anyone's feeling I'm sorry I didn't
want to say that but I was compelled I
don't want if it's not you said not my J
it's not written no you said Dr that I
should reply excuse you will have a
chance in your question answer time sir
I'll let you allow your time in your
time you can respond back no I'll allow
you to respond back anything you want in
your time and I request the chairman to
give me half minute more I was Disturbed
half minute
more no no he's too smart we'll not give
him half minute more see because so many
all egg you told egg is the cause egg
does contain egg does contain
cholesterol it's rich in cholesterol but
it's not the major cause today's
research and medical books also say that
that the cholesterol in the egg is not
the major villain it is the saturated
fat in which you fry the egg butter ghee
lad which is the main villain if you
don't have this frying in ghee butter
the less chances of having ishim heart
disease by egg and today amongst the
population 2/3 of the population are
non-responders to cholesterol the moment
there's high intake of cholesterol like
taking egg the liver immediately Cuts
its own production and the level that
reaches the blood is the same there are
oneir people who are responders to
cholesterol they have a problem they
should abstain from yoke of the egg
otherwise even if you have one or two
egg a day you will not have heart
diseases if you have it with bacon with
porke then the problem if you fry in
ghee you'll have a problem if you fry in
ground nut oil you'll have a problem
causing
baldness I don't want to give
examples I don't to give examples even
if you check here there are many people
are B there are great philosophers who
are Bal I don't want to take the name I
don't to hurt your feelings so this
thing is just a research which is based
on
illogical assumption a research should
be practical and there are associate
factors for heart disease is also
alcohol as well as smoking these two are
also one of the associate causes for
heart diseases yes in America heart
diseas are more non-v because they are
fats Quran says don't have an excess
this problem will be solved secondly the
vegetarians of
America they are fluent it's a woke to
be a vegetarian because you know to buy
veg food is expensive if you TR Mercedes
car you have status if you have veeg
food it is status
there about 3 to 7% of vegetarian in
America less than 1% are pure vegetarian
less than 1% because they are fluent and
they Rich they take more care of hygiene
and many vegetan
ideologically also like even Mr asashi
may agree that alcohol is prohibited
smoking is prohibited because of
associated factors the case of heart
disease in vegetarian is less but anyone
who has food which is rich in
cholesterol or fat irrespective whether
it is veg or non-v he will have heart
disease to prevent it follow the
guidance in the Quran in chapter number
20 verse number 81 that do not commit
excesses that reminds me of a story in
school we had learned that there was a
religious
priest who ate excessive food and he had
64 lus and when he came back his wife
said that why don't you have fur chutki
some digestive so he
says
[Applause]
brother the question is directed to Mr
Rashmi zavi this is a book I have come
across which is named meat eating 100
facts please sir this is not uh not
concerning to you you put your question
saying one book writes like that rather
than saying this person's book or that
you say this book stay so and so that
would be acceptable okay here is a book
from jant publication you being a j I'm
asking you a question which is uh the
name is me eating 100 facts written by
Dr Nami Chand and it gives a cartoonic
representation of uh meat eating people
which I feel it's very insulting and uh
I mean it's degrading I mean defaming so
I just want to ask you in this uh Jes
being tolerant tolerant is it fair
enough for Janss to publish such books
which can hurt people's feeling I mean
is is this it's mockery I mean please
answer yes the speaker would not like to
answer to that I give him the full right
not to answer to the question which a
speaker feels is not suitable we will
allow the second question uh will will
the speaker question okay the next
question please for the he he he passes
that answer he would not like to respond
see the speakers have a right see the I
would request the questioners not to get
worried or agitated in any sort the
speakers have a full right not to
respond or if you feel your question is
not right or not suitable for them they
have a right not to respond back kindly
note so put your question and frame it
in such a way that it is uh not vulgar
neither
derogatory and
yes yes so it should not be derogatory
to the speaker or to a particular Faith
put it in a factual manner this is what
stated what is your opinion don't give
your comment in a derogatory manner ask
what do you say about
this yes don't give your opinion let the
speaker give their opinion on the
subject yes uh sister the next question
for Dr Zakir Alum brother my name is
azra I would like to ask in a book
promoting vegetarianism by gopinath
Agarwal on page 15th and 16th he says
that the milk a cow gives in its
lifetime can satisfy 90 thousand persons
at one time but the same cow is killed
for flesh can satisfy thousand persons
at one time the same applies for goat
also he says killing the goose that lays
a golden egg daily is never a wise
proposition do you agree with
him sister asked a question again from
the same book and I would like to make a
clarification Mr salar he gave these
books and said you can have more books
the letter is there if you want and
these books are available various
markets places people are bound to buy
Etc that's right therefore I'm telling
I'm requesting the people that's right
many
many that's right the brothers asked why
am I repeating because all the arguments
are mentioned
here these arguments if it's not
mentioned here I wouldn't have repeated
it I'll a to please please I think your
tempers must be calm what M Dr what Mr J
what Mr je said very correctly book is
written by somebody else it should it is
he who should try to defend the book Mr
J doesn't want to defend the book so let
us forget the book and ask all questions
which are pertaining to the
talk correct and I agree with
it I agree with it Mr Z he read from
books he didn't do a research he read
books with speaking against
nonvegetarian he read books and he
presented the fact either I accept it or
say the fact is wrong I can't say
because I didn't write the book no one
can ask me
questions that's logical if you ask me
any questions pertaining to non-v food I
either say the book is false or I say
that it's illogical or it's
logical why do you have to get
irritated